okay New York Post has this British
environmental activist demonstrating on
the roads of West London Friday blocked
A desperate mother who claimed that she
needed to cut through the crowd to take
her child to the hospital
we um and despite her pleas the
protesters continue to stand directly in
front of her car while other stalled
Vehicles honked at the crowd to disperse
we have footage of this altercation
let's watch it
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys
this woman has a real newborn baby guys
okay so you get the you see there
they're not getting out of the way for
the car the mother sang she has to get
her baby to the hospital they don't care
uh I think there are two points that I
want to make here two important points
the first is is uh well I think it's a
pretty obvious point that you are
fully morally justified in plowing these
people over and running over them uh to
get your child to the hospital okay they
are a direct threat to your child's
health and safety in life
and if they're not going to get out of
the way you are fully Justified so if
she had just plowed right over them
and killed five of them in the process
it would have been 100 Justified
now
uh is that the way that the court system
in the UK would would look at it when
they're stacking this mother up against
these environmental activists probably
not but that's a reflection of uh
of how broken the court system is both
in the UK and here
but from a from a moral standpoint
totally morally Justified
um and and the people that are breaking
that are blocking traffic
they have no right to be there in the
middle of the road
whatever happens to them when you've got
protesters standing in the middle of the
street the middle of the highway
blocking traffic
whatever happens to them that's on them
and I'm not going to shut a single tier
I don't care at all you you get in the
middle of traffic that's completely on
you you've made your choice
you live with it or die with it
uh but what you really see from from
these environmental activists
and I I think this this particular video
demonstrates it in a really profound
really profound profound way
which is that
they
are concerned these protesters are
so they're deeply concerned for Humanity
right they care about Humanity they're
they're worried about human life on
Earth
supposedly
but they don't care about individual
humans
you notice
we are days away from the Durbin Accords
the greatest threat to the US Dollar's
Global dominance in the past 80 years on
August 22nd the brics nations are
expected to announce the launch of the
new international super currency fully
backed by gold or other Commodities this
is part of their long-term plan to
supplant the U.S and the dollar as the
Cornerstone of the Global Financial
system you can protect your IRA or 401K
from The Fallout from this Landmark
Announcement by diversifying with gold
from Birch gold historically gold has
been a safe haven at times of high
uncertainty which is right now when
currencies fail gold is a safe haven how
much more time does the Dollar have
protect your savings with gold Birch
gold has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers text Walsh to 989898 and
get your free info kit on gold the
Central Bank digital currency becomes a
reality it'll be nice to have some gold
to depend on again text Walsh 298-9898
so they they they're worried about life
on Earth and about these the the climate
change and the fact that there's gonna
they they claim there's an extinction
level event coming and it's always 10
years away somehow it was 10 years away
10 years ago and now it's another 10
years away it always works that way but
that's what they worry about all the
whole human species and not just human
beings but animals and plants and trees
and all life there were they're so
deeply concerned about all life
but they don't give a damn about
individual humans
because then when they're presented with
here's an in here's an actual human
being in the flesh a real person a
distinct human entity
and what you are doing is putting them
in danger
they don't care they can't even be
bothered to move to the side of the road
for five seconds for that person
so this is environmentalism in a
nutshell
it cares deeply about Humanity but not
about individual people which is another
way of saying they don't really care
about Humanity at all they it's they
care about it like in the abstract as a
kind of concept as a slogan as a uh as a
as something that you put on a poster on
a bumper sticker
okay it's only in the abstract do they
care
but when it comes to the health and
well-being and safety of actual real
live people
they don't care
uh this is
you know a a slightly less
drastic example but still really still
really terrible is uh when you see these
same kinds of protesters defacing great
works of art
that's something that if you actually
cared about individual people if you
cared about human beings not Humanity
in the abstract as some sort of concept
but human beings if you cared about
human beings you wouldn't destroy great
works of art
and you wouldn't do that because number
one that great work of art was made by a
human being
who you should respect
and respecting them even if their long
sense dead means means respecting what
what they've created the beauty they've
created but but also
great art brings joy and happiness
to human beings
it brings Beauty into the to the lives
of of actual humans
and so if you cared about actual humans
you would never do that you would never
you would never deface what is beautiful
and good
you especially wouldn't do it in the
name of humanity
so they in when it comes down to it they
don't really care about anyone but
themselves
these are full-on sociopaths and and I'm
I'm probably doing them too much of a
favor by saying they don't care you know
they pretend to get care about Humanity
but they don't care about individual
people
um it's actually worse than that it's
not just they don't care about
individual people they actually hate
individual people
they they despise human life
many of them
um
perfect example of it there hey YouTube
thanks for listening to the show if
you'd like access to my full show with
no ads you should go to dailywire.com
and use promo code walls to get two
months free on all annual plans see you
there